i buried some of these folks who who
would have been alive if it were not for
this defund the police nonsense
these people will never come back we
will never know what they could have
contributed to our america
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here
inside this tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
to you the awareness that you need to
know about the violence on the south
side of chicago but also to raise as
much money as possible to build a
community center on this much-needed
block called oh block it's called
o-block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs took the o in his name
and started calling it oh block well we
decided we like the o but we're going to
change it to opportunity block i want to
thank fox for giving me the opportunity
to come to you every single day to bring
you rooftop revelations where i share
with you my thoughts viewpoints and
opinions on matters as it relates to
violence in chicago and issues from
around our great country
to this very day i can remember when i
first heard the phrase defund the police
america was reeling after the death of
george floyd
how could a law enforcement officer put
his knee on the neck of a man for so
long
a man who was handcuffed and subdued by
three other officers
i've seen a lot of deaths in my
neighborhood on the south side of
chicago
but even this one took the breath out of
me
i can understand how many americans felt
the need to want to do something
they wanted to separate themselves from
from that horror they wanted to believe
that they were better than what they saw
on the video clip
and when black lives matter throughout
defund the police as the solution
many of these americans grabbed onto it
and they donated millions upon millions
of dollars
[Music]
but when i heard defund the police
i heard differently
differently than many americans outside
of our community
i feared that these americans in their
rush to separate themselves from the
death of george floyd
were actually
creating more horror
because my neighborhood is violent i'm
not going to sugarcoat it
the police do everything they can to
keep us safe here
and that's why when black lives matter
tore up our community and
tore up other parts of chicago
i went out with a group of people to
clean up the mess
i wanted to send a message to the police
and
i wanted them to know that they they
they mattered that they had not been
abandoned
that people still had their back and we
wanted them to still have our back
because we in this community know the
truth
no police equals more carnage
but black lives matter and the democrats
refused to listen they kept chanting
defund the police defund the police
including those in our leadership in our
city
bodies kept piling up
and they didn't care they cared more
about politics than lives
absolutely outrageous
my community paid the price not them
and this happened all over america look
at baltimore 36 homicides in baltimore
in the dead code of winter in 2022 let
that sink in we claim to be such good
people and baltimore had his deadliest
january in 50 years i was barely even a
baby
now these democrats
now they they've had the bitter taste of
reality now they want to refund the
police are you freaking kidding me
they chanted black lives matter as they
defunded the police
but how can these lives matter
to them if they're opening the gateway
to murder again
it was about politics not lives
now that they have had their bitter
taste of reality they want to refund the
police
and again i say it has nothing to do
with lies but politics they're only
changing their minds to save their
political career careers i buried some
of these folks who who would have been
alive if it were not for this defund the
police nonsense
these people will never come back we
will never know what they could have
contributed to our america
we will never know
their potential
and there's the hard cold truth the
these black lives matter folks and these
democrats they never came to one of
these funerals they you know why they
don't care
now i'm going to say this america was
fooled the first time around
we better not be fooled the second time
we better not be fooled the second time
so vote
these people out the people who have the
blood of innocence on their hand vote
them out their actions cause these
deaths and they're unfit to lead so vote
them out
that's all i have to say on this matter
thank you for tuning in to another
rooftop revelations and as i say thank
you to fox thank you to eli steele thank
you for terrell filming it
god bless you
god bless america
until tomorrow another rooftop
revelations
peace
you